so I'll make them greens apiece how you
guys doing I am very excited we have a
special guest when we come back MMA
legend Gary Goodrich he's fought with
the best of them all and he has accepted
Islam I'm very happy to hear this good
news and we brought him on to share it
with you let's find out why and find out
the message that he has for you and all
those out there we'll see you in a few
when we come back don't go anywhere
[Music]
assalamualaikum Gary's at you how are
you thank you for being with us for the
audience who doesn't know about many who
are mixed martial arts fans they know
about the legend you've been around you
are doing MMA for how long and when did
you start was that when so that you went
when was it again when the UFC most
people they saw the early you have sees
and they saw hoist Gracie and they got
excited and then they start trainee what
motivated you to get into into this you
were with there's other legends that you
were trained you were were you fighting
with people remember like was it Mark
Coleman and what was what were are some
of the other big names that that were in
your generation
cheering also worries man you just got
inducted in u.s. via two in dark as
result also trained with that everybody
who's anybody had just wanted to learn I
trailer sucker Allah I you know I
trained man I used by her g-spot other
than ever posted me in Tampa
Tom Erickson a wall to uh visit friend
of mine determine who would you say had
the biggest impact on you yes Oh
Muhammad Ali yeah you mentioned
something tell us about this time when
you actually met him he came to one of
your fights both wanna and January 17 so
one of my birthday because he was there
so one of the first by knockout and
biggest hug you know link and forty
students are t-shirt is that one
bracelet and I said were both born the
same the same day January 17 now
everyone knows everyone knows Muhammad
Ali's he's a Muslim American hero he's
someone who is not only known for his
great athleticism and fighting skills
the ring but also fighting for humanity
world peace and all of these other great
things outside of the ring and that's
another thing that you also decided to
follow you you following in his
footsteps you mentioned something when
you saw him you said assalamu alaikum
which means peace be with you so we were
very surprised and very elated to find
out that you also you accepted just like
mohammed islam that that's amazing you
know not only you had that courage that
resilience inside the ring but now i
mean a greater battle nowadays is to
come out because there's a lot of
Islamophobia Islam is the most
misunderstood way of life but it's a
simple way of life it calls you to have
a direct relationship with the one who
created you and most people also after
like you did who are sincere Gary people
who are sincere and genuine they're
searching for purpose in life and they
look into Islam they come to it they
accept it because it's something that
provides the proof the evidences and
it's not something convoluted it's not
something strange and weird worship the
Creator not the creation do good deeds
be the best human being that you can be
and now if you're looking for it you
found it but how is it have you gotten
some backlash because of that decision
that you made
this is a slam people are like me it's
okay I also love them and you know we
talk the talk but that's that's my yeah
a lot of people are I mentioned courage
because they accept Islam it makes sense
the pure monotheism has nothing to do
with all of this you know all this hype
out there many people try to put it
together with radical terrorism and you
know you have obviously in every
religion we don't draw judge Christians
by the KKK we don't judge you know
Italians by the Mafia or you know
there's always going to be elements out
there that do bad things but Islam
doesn't call people to do bad things
it's called people it calls people to do
good things but many people they accept
Islam now they're scared they don't have
the courage to come out but I like what
you said you mentioned that as Muhammad
Ali was carrying the torch you feel like
now this was your responsibility to
continue carrying that torch tell us
about that people you make people to
free them and it's just their own
understandable love this piece is about
together understand because the key or
negative things it's just like when you
see black people sorry Harold always
negative weather back
you know they're never involved and mate
really you trying but the love-letter
drawers you know raping you know so
people people look at that but herself
you know so people are seeing me in my
life but I'm not that like you know and
so you're over trying to tell me boy I
always can end up trying to prove you so
but I'm not going over who you are and
that's what I'm - everybody's afraid
because people are understand Road your
but you know what it's like any other
religion you know you believe in that
you know you know yeah many people don't
know the commonality commonalities
there's so many just like when you just
mentioned something I can't help but to
bring up the point that Jews and
Christians who are Arabic speaking they
also use the word Allah this simply
means God in the in the Bible and the
Arabic Bible Allah is on the first page
17 times it's not a different God it's
the same God it just in the Semitic
language like Jesus he spoke Aramaic he
didn't say God the language of English
didn't exist he would say Aloha Allah
Allah these are the in the Semitic
languages so it's amazing another how do
you when you tell people the love the
deep love obviously we don't worship
Jesus because we believe he didn't call
to be worship he called us to worship
the Creator not the creation so when you
tell people that we love Jesus his
Blessed Mother there's a whole chapter
named after her in the Quran you know
when you mention these commonalities did
you get like facet were you surprised
when you found out that to be a Muslim
you you have to believe in Jesus and all
the other messengers who came with Islam
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation
furthermore them this will be do long
walk carrying their walks hoses but um
they're over the Senate this stuff is
not one this stuff is people like anyone
you know somebody all these I'm shooting
these are with person people these are
on the jury not only Sarah maybe this
was I'm working with nobody it's the
most is the most of religion about that
whatever chance their own they overlook
it and all these radicals but not even
sometimes Melissa cigarette so they're
killing anybody
it's about again alone hurry out and
miss those little people understand you
try to cover mind it just the same you
know you're lucky lucky Rock
we love the true burger down wow I was
not about killing and and blowing up
anything but harmony and these people
were true religion they're sorry
true Muslim they were going to be doing
that at all so they're not yeah many
people at school you bring this point
like what I've mentioned earlier you
have you have bad apples in every Bunch
and to go ahead and to take people who
are who are the the black sheep and to
prompt them up as if they represent
Islam and a lot of times this is a
malicious attempt by the media and
people to create fear and division
amongst the people but I think if people
are genuine when they look at
Muhammad Ali and they look at all the
the great work that he did outside of
the ring he's a great example who
influenced you you know you're an
intelligent person he was a very
intelligent person many people out there
who are accepting Islam is the fastest
growing way of life they are intelligent
elections academics and they're not
going to come into a way of life that is
calling them
to do something evil to oppress humanity
to impress themselves or people they're
like you they're making a you know a
conscious rational decision so that
leads me to my next question when you
started you looked at you started to
look into you you looked into other
religions you look you did how long did
it take you of investigating before you
found that hold on this cannot be a
religion from a man or a group of men
this is indeed from the Creator who
created man how long did it take you to
finally realize that okay after deep
contemplation that Islam is the truth so
the main so you come from a Christian
background and many people don't know
that the really the main difference is
that we don't worship Jesus though we
worship the God of Jesus that's really
like to the point simple the one Jesus
worshipped that's who we worship that's
it simple straightforward one God and
amen yes before we cut out just a couple
more things I wanted to let the audience
in maybe they can help us out
technically we know that you don't have
to change your name if you want to
unless it has bad connotations if it's
something you know bad in the name but
now you actually want to change your
name and you wanted to tell us about
this and maybe we can get some some
feedback from the audience to help pick
up pick a name for you what do you think
and I'm wondering to change my name I
said some African name name but I
definitely change my name
turkeys are gland I believe on Muslim
this is who I am this is my colon
the minute Mohammed Ali died and I'm
going to pick up the torch and carry on
with it this is why I am I need I need I
would like their hot stuff Muslim and
you know what a name I should choose Oh
like people to help me make this
decision whatever decision I come up
with her that's what I'm the general
I need early changing my name to not not
just for show or just for the radio I'm
changing my name completely to whatever
name that it wants to me most under
mashallah
I'm excited about that I'm sure the
artist audience is excited maybe you
guys can help out let's get Gary he
wants your feedback what kind of name do
you think suits him a great strong name
go ahead and share that with us you know
people call me Eddie
that's my middle name my first name is
uh is Meho but it's actually short for
men men men men men is in Turkish
Mohammed so I I was I was also debating
now that I think I want to be start
being called that name also more meth
men so you you actually helped to
motivate me to do something with the
name also so I thank you for that I try
but you can you know rainfall order if
you like her even be with the room with
a lot where you can be yourself there's
not gonna na with it just be the best
you he is gonna be be the best you can
be
great advice couple more questions
before we cut out hutch we are talking
about HUD you would like to go to Hajj
[Music]
you got here that did you guys hear that
we want to get our brother Gary
Goodridge he wants to go to Hajj let's
go ahead we had some brothers from the
canadian dollar associations the people
that brought out Dave Chappelle and Mike
Tyson and and others letting you guys
know about Gary or any other
organization let's try to get him to
Hajj let's try to make it happen and
with that said what advice Gary do you
have for others Islam is simple Islam is
beautiful Islam promotes peace just as
mercy for all
it's about pure monotheism it's about
doing good in humanity making the world
a better place while you're in this
place before you go to the next place
what advice do you have for others who
are who are accepting Islam who are out
there in the public eye but they're now
timid they're scared what people gonna
do they might be have courage to get in
the ring but they're scared to go ahead
and and and live up to that identity of
being a Muslim what advice do you have
for them
Royston others I don't want to put
anyone at harm's away but be proud of
who you are this is who I am I'm very
proud of very hopeful of Who I am as he
is caring my Facebook and Twitter
missile I am so I was said about how the
people don't pay fertile you are a lot
of brothers to be here and once uh you
know once as always do laughter people
won't believe in them uncle soon did
don't pay for it you know sometimes you
have to be afraid in quarter in order to
you know your current surroundings but
down level key Joe it was an honor thank
you so much made the crater that happens
at Earth Allah rewards you thank you it
was an honor to have you on the deso
alaikum salam' hamdulillah that was our
brother Gary Goodridge now he wants a
new name and I said you don't
technically have to change it but he
wants to so let's help him out go ahead
in the comments start leaving what you
guys think will be a suitable name for
Gary he really would like your guys
input and we want to get him to Hajj you
know Islam is based on five pillars real
simple to understand one is that you
testified that there's nothing worthy of
worship it's in your nature you could do
it everyone can do it Jesus did it Moses
did it last and final message narrow
Muhammad did it that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the one who
created you doesn't that is that fair is
that reasonable it's real simple you're
gonna agree what's in your nature you
could do it nothing worthy of worship
except the one who created you I'm not
gonna worship anything in creation not a
man not a woman not the Sun not the moon
nothing in creation but the one who
created creation that's the first step
and then I'm gonna knowledge that he
sent a messenger for all of mankind and
Muhammad is the final messenger and that
would automatically include and exclude
all the preceding messengers Jesus Moses
Abraham Noah they all came with the same
simple message worship the one who
created you it's simple and don't
worship anything else and then you
establish the prayer five times a day
minimum fasting during the month of
Ramadan and then paying the poor due to
the poor and then you
HoJ Gary wants to go to Hajj can we make
it happen
could the oma help make it happen let's
go ahead I know there's somebody out
there an organization or individual you
want to sponsor his trip go ahead let's
put it together let's make it happen and
I hope that in sha allah that we can go
ahead and with open arms welcome our
brother to the dean and those who are
watching who have also accepted it then
go and take this advice and have that
courage be the torchbearers of like what
Muhammad Ali and what Gary wants to do
continuing his legacy because he was a
Muslim American Hero Muhammad Ali he
wasn't a terrorist terrifying people
wrecking havoc in the earth no if you
look at his track record what was he
doing he was living in LA Muhammad Ali
and he was helping humanity because
that's what it's LOM calls to it calls
you to be the best version of yourself
it's LOM is l am islam says love all
mankind and how can you be loving all
mankind if you're blowing up and kind
that doesn't make sense so do what's in
your nature do a Muhammad Ali do what
all the messengers of God did submit to
the Creator not the creation do good
deeds prepare for what comes next
because this life is transitory it's
going to come to an end so when you live
a righteous life here you're gonna be
blessed over there and you'll be blessed
here so thank you very much for tuning
in thank you Gary for being on the D
show
let's help pick that name and get him to
Hajj we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you oh don't forget to
subscribe
get the notification so you can get all
of our shows sent to you when they come
out peace assalam alaikum gonna do the
next 16 years what's the best thing get
ready to meet God
in real estate learning business
teaching boxes that won't get me to
heaven God is watching me
God is God don't praise me because I
beat Joe Frazier I don't care about
Engel of America as far as real wealth
that's all he is he wants to know how do
we treat each other how do we help each
other so I'm gonna dedicate my life to
using my name of popularity helping
charities helping people you know young
people bring people bombing each other
because the religious believes we need
somebody in the world to help us make
peace so when I die if there's a heaven
I want to see it because we live how
long 80 years
the odds are everybody in this room some
of you will be dead 20 years ago some of
you will be dead 50 years ago some of
them be dead thirty someone be there 60
70 years we all want to die soon so this
is a test to see where will we spend our
life and have them help this is not the
life left your real self is inside you
your body gets old some of you go to
look at the freaky little you'll have no
teeth
your hair is leaving you your bodies get
tired but your soul and your spirit
never dies
that's what if ever so your body is just
housing your soul in spirit
so God is testing us on how we treat
each other that we live to see where our
real home be and heaven so this physical
stuff don't answer so low so my car this
building is gonna be here when the man
who built a dam there been many kings
and queens of England they're all dead
after this one is gone another to come
so we don't stay here we're just
trustees we don't own nothing even your
children are not yours if you think I'm
loud your wife is not yours you don't
own your children you know and your
family so what am I saying
the most important thing about life is
what's going to happen when you die are
you gonna go to have on the hill and
that's eternity
how long is eternity so what am I gonna
do it I'm through fighting I'll have 16
years agrees with doctor get myself
ready to meet God and go to the best
place what they make sense thank you
you